this is interacting with nature on a
whole new level
these guys have hacked nature to create
a beautiful artistic collaboration
between humankind and insects so how did
these artists get thousands of fireflies
to dance to their human tune the duo set
up about 40 LEDs in the forest and
programmed them to go on and off at
regular intervals the fireflies
responded by flashing back fireflies are
actually not flies at all they're
different kinds of winged beetles and
different species flash for different
reasons to warn off predators or to
attract a mate some species don't flash
at all Robin and Andre have chosen to
use a species of fireflies called to
optics maliki which are among the 1% of
fireflies that synchronize their flashes
in large groups they flash naturally at
regular intervals but if they notice
another firefly nearby flashing they'll
interrupt their own pattern and start
over again every time it resets the
neural cycles of those two individual
fireflies will become more closely
matched within a few cycles the two
individuals will synchronize and begin
to flash at exactly the same time
eventually the whole tree begins
flashing in unison this process is
called entrainment robin and under a
have basically used the fact that the
fireflies can't tell the difference
between another firefly flashing and an
LED light flashing to basically hijack
the synchronization process in the video
these guys have used technology to
imitate nature but then nature turn
around and imitated that technology
right back
[Music]
you